[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire avait été
la 21e édition de la revanche at s'est
déroulée ce dimanche sur la colline
d'elancourt 160 participants ont dû
s'employer sous la chaleur pour
remporter la victoire tous les détails
dans ce magazine produit à cet officiel
les équipes seniors du sky et de
montigny le bretonneux vont fusionner
l'équipe première évoluera en honneur
nous recevrons sur ce plateau les deux
présidents des deux clubs
insolite une équipe yvelinoise baptisé
titanic va participer à au red bull
jourdan vol ce week-end à lyon
compétition délurée où les participants
doivent propulser leurs revenus du haut
d'une plate forme de s'y mettre
l'équipe sera avec nous dans quelques
instants l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
on commence tout de suite par du
cyclisme et plus précisément du vtt la
21e édition de la revanche à bhl était
organisée ce dimanche matin sur la
colline d'elancourt futur site olympique
pour les jo de 2024 événement regroupait
encore cette année plus d'une centaine
de participants en montage de sandrine
fontaine dimanche 23 juin 9h30 160 cours
se sont réunis au pied de la colline
d'elancourt pour participer à la 21e
édition de la revancharde une course de
vtt qui se tiendra cette année sous des
températures estivales et pour dompter
au mieux le thermomètre chacun a sa
technique
moi c'est déjà d'essayer de finir et pas
me cramer tout de suite au départ pour
pouvoir finir proprement parce que c'est
quand même assez long
kazim heure et demie faut ménager la
monture comme on dit qui veut aller loin
ménage sa monture donc là ça va être les
premiers tours un peu en dedans et après
on verra vers la fin sont peu un peu
développé les les chevaux cette année un
tracé de 5 9 km a été imaginé par les
organisateurs sur le futur site
olympique des compétitions de vtt en
2024 niveau difficulté assez élevé quand
même voilà après fo fo est assez
technique par endroit il ya un peu de
roulement faut savoir faire du vtt
pendre je sais que voilà là où il
s'aventure avec leurs vélos moi je
descendrai je descendrai à côté c'est
sûr et certain n'ont pas réussi à
surmonter les difficultés ayant dû
s'arrêter dès le deuxième tour c'est
super difficile mais j'ai pas du tout à
condition pour voilà c'est simple on
sait comment ça je serais déçu si
c'était sur une casse lui a bien boucler
ses cinq tours nicolas 10 mai de
gif-sur-yvette remporte cette édition
hugo parmentier parti devant il y avait
20 à 30 secondes d'avancé suite avec
cédric chartier on est revenus tous les
deux petit à petit et voilà ensuite on a
fait le petit groupe de trois et ensuite
on s'est attaqué juste dans la fin la
dernière bosse en parallèle l'événement
a permis de récolter près de 2500 euros
en faveur des orphelins des sapeurs
pompiers
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition on continue par du
baseball contre performance pour les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux lors
de la première journée des playoffs de
première division les immondes 1 se sont
inclinés lors de leurs deux matchs
contre oran le score 4 à 2 dans la
première rencontre et 11 à 3 dans la
seconde partie les cougars n'ont plus le
choix ils devront réaliser un quasi sans
faute pour espérer se qualifier en
finale nationale comme l'année dernière
on voit maintenant sortir les ballons
ovales c'est désormais officiel les
équipes seniors de
montigny-le-bretonneux et du sky rugby
vont fusionner les deux présidents des
deux clubs
jacques moreau et lionel garrigues et
sont avec nous sur ce plateau pour nous
parler de cette fusion bonsoir alors je
vois que vous avez le sourire mais j'ai
le sourire parce qu'on est on est en
train de construire un beau projet
nous avons nous avons réussi à à lancer
cette fusion que qui était dans les
tuyaux depuis lothar mais sans jamais se
faire et
et donc c'est maintenant certain cet
acte et nos équipes seniors
mais pas seulement nos équipes seniors
des équipes cadets vont jouer sous le
même maillot la saison prochaine
dès la saison prochaine depuis quand à
peu près vous l'avais imaginé cette
fusion lionel personnellement en 2009
2010 lorsque le sky rugby a été créé
je crois que tu avais été approché
jacques mais voilà nous et nous sommes
deux clubs deux clubs qui qui avons vécu
nous nos parcours respectifs de club et
me voilà dans les années d'ailleurs 2000
2012 2013 2014 je pense on avait fait
une entente en cadets juniors qu'ils
avaient d'ailleurs deux titres de
champion de france est plus folle est à
cette époque donc il y avait quelque
chose de fonctionnel et ça peut
fonctionner ça va fonctionner c'est
évident c'est évident et ce mariage du
coup comment quand ça va s'articuler
expliquez-nous jacques basset
relativement simple sur les catégories
que j'ai cités c'est à dire les seniors
l'équipe première du club
les juniors les cadets il ya une seule
équipe une seule équipe
donc si on parle des seniors donc nous
allons évoluer en division d'honneur qui
était le niveau qu'occuper sky rugby
l'année dernière donc on montigny le
bretonneux disparue mais porto ne
disparaît complètement nue ou le
seigneur menti et cantonné à abandonner
sa place en promotion d'honneur nous
avons failli monter en honneur dernière
mais nous ne l'avons pas fait donc il y
aura un stand durant une seule équipe ce
qui va ce qui laisse quand même présager
de bonnes choses avec avec une équipe
qui s'était maintenue sans difficulté le
sky rugby un honneur et une équipe qui
avait failli monter en honneur l'année
dernière on est raisonnablement
optimiste sur l'année prochaine 160 se
mettre des ambitions démesurées mais on
a on a surtout des joueurs qui ont joué
ensemble quand il était cadet junior
c'était ce que de ce que disent et
lionel qui ont une grosse envie de
recommencer à jouer ensemble
il ya une certaine cohérence en fait
depuis la wii est cohérent pour les
choses doivent se faire des vestaires
c'était peut-être un peu plus lent qu'on
ne peut l'imaginer mais mais par les
temps qui courent le rugby ribéry est un
petit peu en difficulté globalement au
niveau de la france et les effectifs se
rétrécissent un petit peu donc oui les
logiques lunettes garrigues jacques
parle de nécessité c'est bien ca de la
société
j'applaudis le rugby est un petit peu en
difficulté en france avec une perte
d'effectif on n'aurait pas pu continuer
dans cet état parce que on aurait pu
continuer mais avec des vraies
difficultés ça il faut être ce qui m'a
tout à fait réaliste je pense que on a
terminé la saison avec un groupe de 30
34 joueurs en 35 joueurs pour faire deux
équipes c'est impossible si on se
projette
c'est impossible de faire vivre des
clubs avec un effectif aussi réduit
on a au niveau national on a perdu entre
10 et 15% selon les régions c'est
compensé par les féminines qui
heureusement marche bien au niveau au
niveau national et là je pense
qu'effectivement c'était une opportunité
et qu'il fallait la saisir maintenant
c'était c'était l'occasion ou jamais je
dirais même si d'autres personnes je
pense souhaitait le faire de manière
encore plus
vous êtes allé plus lente il fallait le
faire cette année il y aura combien déjà
du coup la saison prochaine c'est bien
on a du mal à préjuger du chiffre si on
regarde si on regarde nos effectifs et
que l'on actuelle je pense qu'on peut on
peut imaginer que l'autre on ne reçoit
plus de 70 joueurs je pense avec les
faits avec l'effet d'aubaine qui va sans
doute à paraître pour certains joueurs
je pense que collectivement il ya déjà
des gens qui vont adhérer à ce projet
qui puisse le joueur dit peut-être
également plus de qualité également dans
l'effectif jacques moret numériquement
forcément forcément on désignera la
crème de la crème si je peux dire à
tourner à deux équipes qui va quitter
finalement un peu proches l'une de
l'autre les unes en milieu de tableau
d'honneur l'autre des tables autour de
100 donneurs
legrand la grande équipe ce qu'il a
bénéficié l'équipe qui va bénéficier le
plus de ça c'est l'équipe réserve
puisque l'équipe réserve et est en
difficulté au spi rugby elle était en
grande difficulté chez nous puisque nous
avons fait forfait général en cours
d'année
des joueurs qui ont beaucoup souffert et
là on va avoir une vraie concurrence en
première qui va amener des joueurs de
qualité en équipe réserve et je suis
convaincu qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'en
dehors en équipe première mais je suis
convaincu qu'on aura une très belle
équipe réserve et qui va guider
du coup cette équipe senior je te le
club il ya quatre entraîneurs qui sont
d'ores et déjà désigné et au travail
phénomène qu'on ne s'était donc se sont
ils proviennent les proviennent des deux
clubs ils sont des deux clubs donc il y
à touba payen c'est une trainer du super
rugby et il ya les trois entraîneurs qui
était en poste à montigny c'est à dire
françois margot récit est le meurtrier
et xavier mitouart vraiment mélanger
sans la comprendre a un groupe qui est
vraiment qui s'inscrit dans le mélange
est très motivé et on a honnêtement qui
sont pas techniques un très beau groupe
d'entraîneurs pour pour le niveau où on
va évoluer la présidence ça va se
dérouler comme une coprésidence convenu
me levant acteurs c'est que nous l'avons
inscrite dans les statuts pas de manière
définitive on peut très bien c'est pas
très bien effectivement s'interrompre un
jour lorsqu'il y aura saturation pour
l'autre pour d'autres personnes en tout
cas c'est une co présidence c'est pareil
le bureau i télé qui est équilibré en
amont a tenu à ce que chacun chacun des
deux clubs fournissent qui un souk la
terre
en l'occurrence ça sera une secrétaire
général que je connais très bien
puisqu'il s'agit de mon épouse
la trésorie qui est fournie par par
jacques moreau en la personne d'emmanuel
moreau et puis cargo pardon pardon
et puis secrétaire adjoint qui vient de
qui provient de de
montigny-le-bretonneux tandis que le
trésorier sera trésorier adjoint sarah
thomas païens qui exerçait déjà les
fonctions de trésorier l'année dernière
où skyrim
non il n'y a pas de gros bouleversements
sièges contre amiens non non non non au
contraire un équilibre sur un an contre
des deux clubs au niveau des joueurs
comment ils ont réagi
ses joueurs à 26 bretagne comme on a
réagi alors à de très rares exceptions
près les joueurs étaient très contents
parce qu'on arrivait c'est une fin de
cycle à montigny on a un groupe qui a un
coût qui a fait plusieurs bonnes saisons
de suite qui a eu du mal à monter en
promotion d'honneur mais qui a fini par
y arriver
qui cette année a fait la meilleure
saison de son histoire à feront les
frais de la montée il n'a pas fait mais
avec un groupe restreint et
je pense qu'on était au maximum de ce
qu'on pouvait faire avec ce look
finalement que le groupe était pas assez
nombreux et la perspective de jouer avec
des gens dont la plupart se connaissent
enfin les beaucoup de ses joueurs s'ils
n'ont pas joué ensemble avec des étés
cadets et juniors qui se sont fréquentés
au lycée j'étais très étonné on a fait
une réunion avec les deux
les deux groupes de joueurs à 4 en
passant ils se connaissent et ils donc
ils sont enchantés c'est vraiment le
terme ils sont enchantés de jouer
ensemble et même les très rares un peu
réticent au début parce que c'est vrai
que c'est la fin d'une histoire
quand on vous annonce à la fin du club
banon ses débuts c'est début d'autre
chose
j'ai même ce genre là il mais ça y est
ils adhèrent au projet mais je pense
aussi qu'on vécu ça va se passer
et le club enfin la structure va se
doter d'un nouveau nom est ce que vous
nous le présenter
lionel oui ça n'a pas été très simple
beaucoup de en fait il fallait au nom
d'une certaine équité
j'ai trouvé un nom neutre
en fait tout simplement parce que d'une
part le sky rugby ne pouvait plus
vis-à-vis de plaisir qui est dans la
ville nouvelle par exemple pour
revendiquer le titre de
le club de saint quentin en yvelines et
puis d'autre part
dans ce cas l umih on ne pouvait pas
plus claire du bi montini puisque
montigny effectivement toutes les villes
sont effectivement contributives à un
effort donc il a fallu trouver un autre
il n'est pas très joli on s'en fiche un
petit peu ce sera ça sera urs et 78
union rugby centre 78 l'important c'est
que chacun y trouve son compte et que on
reste représentatif du rugby saint
quentinois et ça nos élus peuvent en
être convaincu il est temps que local le
club gagne c'est le plus important je
crois que c'est effectivement la
finalité
merci à tous et devait passer sur ce
bateau on vous souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur dans ce nouveau mariage et on a
hâte de voir les joueurs sur le terrain
au mois de septembre
golf à présent nous vous en parlions la
semaine dernière d'après une étude la
ryder cup 2018 qui s'est déroulée au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines en septembre dernier aurait
boosté l'activité économique de la
france à hauteur de 235 millions d'euros
pour une semaine de compétition les
revenus concerne à la fois les
restaurants les hôtels les transports
une première réussie pour une veille de
recueil sur le sol français qui donne
envie aux instances françaises
d'organiser de nouveau cette compétition
l'écoutent le dtn du golfe neuf français
et christophe muniesa
pour ce qui est de la ryder cup il ya un
processus de candidature et ont fait et
l'on est complet et que la fenêtre
la prochaine fenêtre de tir ne sera pas
avant 2026 voire 2030
donc oui on est très clairement motivé
pour candidater de nouveau à l'accueil
de ce type de compétition nous allons
parler football et du paris
saint-germain le club s'installera bien
à poissy tous les signaux sont au vert
pour le futur campus un avis favorable a
été officiellement émis par les
commissaires enquêteurs après deux ans
de concertation avec les partenaires et
les habitants le projet prévoit la
création d'une quinzaine de terrains
d'entraînement à l'hébergement pour les
joueurs professionnels et les jeunes
ainsi qu'un stade de 5000 places
coût total de l'opération entre 250 et
300 millions d'euros
les travaux commenceront à la rentrée
pour une livraison au premier trimestre
2009 un hameau un mercato à présent
c'est l'un des transferts records de cet
été ferland mendy vient d'être transféré
de lyon au real madrid pour un chèque de
50 millions d'euros une somme qui
devrait profiter au fc mantois 78 le
club yvelinois vais récupérer 0,5 pour
cent de la somme près de 240 mille euros
ce pourcentage représente l'année à deux
formations que le latéral gauche a passé
au club entre
1012 et 2013 en compte en catégorie u19
une somme qui pourrait aider dans les
prochaines années le club de nationale 3
rétrogradé par la dncg le mois dernier
chien football toujours la coupe
d'afrique des nations a débuté vendredi
dernier en egypte
elle réunit les meilleures sélections
africaines dans les yvelines une canne
locales et amateur a vu le jour pendant
le mois de juin à mantes la jolie
les habitants se sont affrontés selon
leur origine la finale de l'événement
s'est déroulé la semaine dernière et
attiré près de 3000 supporteurs dans le
val fourré comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images c'est finalement à la
république démocratique du congo qu'il a
remport emporté 2 1 face au sénégal
nouvelle édition devrait être organisé
pour la prochaine coupe d'afrique des
nations direction à présent le club de
football de trappes l'annoncé tombée à
ce week-end en assemblée général
mustapha larbaoui a décidé de quitter la
structure après 16 années passées au
club en 14 à sa présidence potentiel
tête de liste à la mairie de la commune
i ne voudrais pas mélanger les gens en
écoute justement la réaction de mustapha
larbaoui avec la politique
l'éducateur dans la campagne durant les
campagnes au respect en dehors du champ
politique pour l'association est réservé
soit l'association au delà de la sphère
donc vous la pluie qu'à moi même tout
simplement
mustapha larfaoui a déjà annoncé qu'il
viendrait régulièrement le week-end pour
supporter ses désormais ex joueur mais
depuis elle les tribunes
abderrezak question reste président du
club encore du football dans ce set 8
sport le mercato d'été a déjà commencé à
poissy laurent fournier ancien joueur de
l'om ou du psg et ex entraîneur du paris
saint germain s'est engagé avec le club
pisciacais pour une saison au minimum
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
[Musique]
ma vie parce que c'est ce qui m'a permis
de grandir de m'épanouir de gagner des
trophées et d'être bien dans sa peau
c'est compliqué à répondre à cette
question mais je vois le football en
pleine progression
financièrement pour les joueurs mais
manque de spontanéité manque de
créativité
c'est bon de retrouver des joueurs comme
quand même bape et qui commence qui
recommencent à faire rêver
[Musique]
toute ma carrière je crois que j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 15 ans j'étais avec
des grands garçons
j'ai fini à 34 ans 20 ans de carrière
après il ya les championnats avec paris
avec marseille
les coupes d'europe avec paris
toutes ces victoires avec ses bandes de
potes c'est la solidarité qui avait à
l'époque dans toutes les équipes où j'ai
joué on continue à parler football on va
prendre la direction de magny les
hameaux pour la sixième année
consécutive un tournoi amical en hommage
à l'ancien capitaine du club franck
klimko s'est déroulée samedi au stade
jacques anquetil au rendez vous a réuni
dix équipes venues de l'île de france
dont les clubs de jouy en josas et
montigny le bretonneux présent depuis
les débuts on écoute les réactions au
micro d'aurélie ronsin mais ça fait on a
mis quatre ans à peu près avoir cette
idée et du coup là ça fait six ans qu'on
pérennise le tournoi et je pense que vu
le monde qu'il ya aujourd'hui et vu
comment ça fonctionne chaque année ça a
l'air de ça à l'air de bien marcher du
coup déjà c'est pour rendre un hommage
je rende hommage à la personne qu'on
connaissait à francky mco et et revoir
des amis qu'on voit pas tout le temps
est passé une super journée ensoleillée
en plus après une journée de compétition
c'est finalement fonte et le fleury qui
emporte le tournoi pour sa première
participation
après une large page football du tir à
l'arc le club deville preuve que fêté ce
samedi sa quarantième année d'existence
autour d'un repas et d'une démonstration
de tir créée en 1979 le club qui
participent principalement à des
compétitions régionales et
départementales compte aujourd'hui entre
50 et 60 adhérents de 12 à 80 ans pour
durer dans le temps le club a mis en
place certaines valeurs depuis sa
création l'écoutent le président on a
quelques valeurs qui sont la
transmission de la connaissance donc on
est beaucoup dans la dans
l'accompagnement dans la formation
donc ça c'est une des valeurs ensuite la
discipline et l'exigence parce que
faire du tir c'est un loisir c'est du
plaisir mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de pratique beaucoup d'exigence
en terme de pratique donc le mot
discipline prend vraiment tout ça toute
sa dimension
et puis il ya le respect on passe
maintenant à notre page agenda on
continue ce magazine par un rendez vous
insolite une équipe versaillaise baptisé
à titanic va participer à red bull jours
d'un vol ce week-end à lyon une
compétition délurée où les participants
doivent propulser un ovni du haut d'une
plate-forme de 6 mètres nous recevons
l'équipe sur ce plateau emmanuel alexis
et lætitia rocher ainsi qu'arthur bitton
bonsoir bonsoir ça alors est-ce que vous
êtes prêts emmanuel je vais laisser
d'abord l'art sur ce qui est un peu plus
volubile que moi donc il n'ya pouvoir
vous présenter
déjà pour vous vous présentez un peu
plus un peu plus globalement on
représente une chaîne qui s'appelle nos
fins de semaine c'est une chaîne youtube
qui au fait des faits des projets un peu
technique filmé en forêt genre
tyrolienne saut pendulaire et c est
forcément arrivé sur un événement qui
apportait un peu plus de fraîcheur dans
notre dans notre chaîne était très
intéressant pour nous et du coup voilà
vous avez du goût des deux de se lancer
là dedans alors justement le on a vu les
images du titanic
comment vous l'avez conçu les manuels et
ben alors déjà on appris surtout des
palettes en fait qu'on a désossé et et
après on a acheté ce qui sert de tôle en
fait pour les fixer dessus et en fait
c'est beaucoup de récupération de on les
a trouvés sur la route et
du coup ça nous a pas coûté très cher
200 euros environ
et puis après on a mis à la peinture
c'est tout simple après ça prend un peu
de temps mais ça impressionne ambiance
conviviale on a pris trois semaines
environ
et tout le monde a travaillé sur le
projet plus personnel je fais je
m'occupe des déguisements parce que il
faut des déguisements pour la
chorégraphie les italiens bas au début
de fin sur l'événement on passe on est
une équipe de 4 donc moi je suis pas je
fais pas partie de l'équipe mais je
serais je te suffit à côté et en fait on
doit ils sont tous déguisés ils font une
sorte de chorégraphie et ils poussent
donc le titanic dans l'eau et moi du
coup je m'occupe de la partie
déguisement c'est l'exil ressembleront à
quoi ces des déguisements d'icebergs ne
dit pas ses secrets au fait que titanic
hyper-sûr et percuté l'iceberg
et comment ça s'est passé il fallait
envoyer un dossier de candidature c'est
ça ouais alors c'est surtout ma nuque
sur n'occupe mais il ya un dossier
il y avait une certaine deux par deux
deux personnes qui ont demandé à faire
une inscription et puis et puis il ya
une quarantaine de 30 40 30 34 qui a
participé 34 équipes qui vont participer
et même parmi ces que 34 équipes on va
être on va être suivie par w9
parce que ils ont bien aimé notre projet
et du cou et du coup voilà on est suivi
par beaucoup de télévision et est ce que
c'est une fierté
je pense que participer à la pré version
en disant que ça revient en france
non mais c'est une grande fierté et puis
je pense qu'on a plus d'une corde à
noeuds sac
donc je pense qu'on est on peut gagner
on peut gagner on peut avoir un prix et
je pense qu'on a nos chances quoi voilà
pourquoi le titanic juste à l'idée est
quand même il ya vous avez deux prix un
peu il m'a pris un peu technique et un
prix de créativité et on a préféré miser
sur la sur la créativité sur nos
compétences en tant qu'ingénieur c'était
plus facile les plus vives rigolo pour
nous de faire ça tous ensemble et ce
sont des notes sur 10 c'est bien sa
société la denture distincts l'objectif
c'est d'aller le plus loin possible
enfin la logique voudrait que ça aille
le plus loin possible je pense que mon
fils lui tend le salto avant que
cinquante mètres mais et pourquoi si la
gravité vous avez mis je crois les
pilotes à l'avancé ça exactement
en fait on voulait représenter la
fameuse scène du titanic où il ya
justement rose et jack qui se tiennent
et du coup le pilote est à l'avant dans
la logique de la scène et du coup au
niveau de la gravité ouais c'est pas top
quoi est ce qu'il ya un projet
finalement c'est que on a à peu près
certain que ce sera un échec mais est ce
qu'on s'était entraîné à cet échec
c'est notre but c'est d'être ce soit en
échec finalement mais est ce que vous
êtes en train de bafouer demandé au
pilote parce que c'est lui qui va
prendre les plus grands risques
on va voir on va voir oui on s'est
préparé on s'est quand même à peu près
ce que ça va donner mais bon on sait
jamais on n'a pas pu tester le truc
malheureusement mais on va voir ce que
ça donne on a prévu quelques voies de
secours au cas où on va un peu trop vite
on pourra il pourra toujours se tait au
dernier moment quand les voies de
secours c'est-à-dire des voies de
secours
marceau on veut toujours plus toujours
trouver une solution donc le fera si m
ça vous fait pas peur bah on m'a regardé
en bas côté on se pose pas de questions
face on n'est pas là pour réfléchir
ouest
c'est pas c'est l'intelligence au
service de la connerie alors comme quand
on l'a vu sur les images à fait
spectaculaire comment ont réagi vos
proches laetitia alors moi alors moi
déjà j'ai rejoint l'équipe un peu plus
tard donc c'est pas moi qui ai présenté
l'idée est tout donc je pense que c'est
plus de 2 qui ont ils
les réactions les plus alexis non
globalement un très un très bon accueil
et puis et puis même là encore avant
dans l'histoire il y avait du monde à la
maison ils ont pu ils ont pu découvrir
un peu nostalgique et puis voir un peu
les projets c'est sympathique
vous avez été soutenue alors
financièrement welti seul soutien moral
psychologique
normand pas particulièrement on n'a pas
demandé de financement
et puis et puis non c'est que de la boue
des bruits puisque même pour apporter le
titanic à lyon ce qui fait quand même
six mètres de long et donc sur ses six
mètres de long et bien faut les
transporter et nous on va prendre nos
remorques ont à emprunter
voilà c'est que de la débrouille qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter ce sera ma
dernière question des déchets
quand même vous est fixé un nombre de
mètres à parcourir ou pas du tout merci
en tout cas d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour ce week-end je rappelle
c'est à lyon on suivra avec attention
votre performance
à noter également dans vos agendas la
21e et dernière étape du tour de france
partira le 28 juillet depuis rambouillet
le peloton s'élancera à 18h05 exactement
pour 128 km à les coureurs passeront
ensuite par les bréviaires l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay y sont à saint rémy les
chevreuse vers 19 heures 11 avant de
quitter le département château fort pour
rejoindre les champs-elysées
les sportifs seront évidemment précédée
par la caravane et on termine par un
rendez vous insolite qui sont organisées
ce week-end au vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le crossfit
french soit d'hommes 3500 athlètes sont
réunis pour la toute première fois dans
la structure le rendez-vous permettra
d'élire les sportifs qui participeront
crossfit games 2019 les portes du
vélodrome ouvriront à partir de 7h30 le
prix du ticket varie entre 20 et 60
euros
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
il